[Music]
I have a very special surprise Allah I'm
Kelly
I got Kelly Clarkson I was like that's
so cool I can't wait to be a Jennifer
because we know what it's like yes oh my
god oh my god I'm Kelly this is not
happening
y'all both seeing the same genre a
different runner I'm real pop my new
thang Cyndi Lauper I do a lot of that is
it possible that you talk more than
Molly do you know me at all
coming to this show is like what you
wish radio sounded like Kelly you need a
TV show and get old trust me no you're
gonna be a force in country music oh I
hope so yeah I can already see the
headlines now like Blake and Adam over
Adam and Kelly new best friends it's so
much better than the original and I can
say that because I am the original it's
my god you're like the coolest ever I do
too I wrote her now I stomp a cliff my
eyes is the main town dip just dip into
that oh dear this is my job lock eyes
with the audience like I could rock your
world or wreck your day she's crying oh
my god
thank you
we're so good at this and I love you so
much I hate to have to destroy you next
you are full of it sir he's dumb for
putting both of you together
so the first time she's ever called me
but you just own it
that's what I do and sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't I love this job
[Music]
you
[Music]